It's been five years since black water
originally aired and its explosion of
wildfires,
still a sight to behold,
but besides it's visual appeal,
it's in this moment through the death of
hundreds in which the true nature of the
various characters involved are laid
bare.
It's these reactions they have and the
decisions they make in the face of death
rather than the visual spectacle of war
itself that makes this episode and game
of thrones as a whole,
as great as it is now,
last season,
we got to experience what it's like to
see another battle play out in this time
on a much higher budget,
but the battle of the bastards is in a
lot of ways the opposite of black water.
The main focus here is on the visual
rather than the moral and psychological.
It's about the feeling of chaos for John
and the horror of medieval warfare
itself.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
it's a tremendous visual sequence that
dwarfs every battle previously seen on a
show or TV in general for that matter,
but it's also sequenced.
That's lacking in the aspects that make
game of thrones unique.
The Battle of the best verses a struggle
between the forces of good and forces of
evil,
whereas blackwater is a fight between
two sites,
none of which are portrayed as being
more benevolent or ill intention.
Then the other nearby effectively
confusing the audience and who to root
for.
It's in this fog of war at writer George
Rr Martin has decided to depict the
battle through the eyes of various
individuals,
individuals from both sides who are all
dealing with the stress and the anxiety
that comes with the reality of death and
their own particular way.
We can see it in devils,
retaining his sense of level headed
pragmatism and in the fanatical faith of
his son we received in Tyrian resorting
to one last night of lovemaking and
accepting his fate.
As a military commander,
we see it in prideful nihilism stenosis,
content,
demeanor,
bronze drinking,
the hound cynicism.
It's a show of character in the face of
death,
a stripping away of all the
superficialities that normally shout the
true essence of who these people truly
are.
Don't get killed.
No,
you my friend.
Oh,
are we friends now?
Of course we are,
or as we'll showed her,
puts it well.
It was expanding on the thoughts of
William Faulkner,
the only thing or if writing about is
the human heart in conflict with itself.
We all have it in us to be angels and
all of those have it in us to be
monsters.
What matters is the decisions we make at
two crucial periods and times of our
life and it's during the times when
death,
disability stone's throw away,
that our most authentic self will
consciously or unconsciously come to
light
by placing the emphasis on the decisions
and the mortality of individuals in
battle.
Rather than framing this story in a more
conventional and simplistic good versus
bad struggle.
It provides the audience for our very
own conflict of heart as we're now
invited to seed our world in a more
nuance and a more human manner,
no longer rooting for sides,
for instead rooting for the individual,
empathizing with them,
or at the very least,
truly learning something about their
nature.
For King Joffrey,
this means is show of cowardice or
perhaps also evidence of is harmful
upbringing by a cynical mutter who
ultimately shows herself to be akin to
the prideful destructiveness of real
life,
mocked a goebbels,
but on the other hand we also get a
sense of why it is that she became a
hateful person.
She shows herself to be she drunkenly,
spouts out her resentments towards her
father and her role as a woman in the
family.
It was expected of me as it will be a
view if you ever become joffrey's queen,
but in the midst of all the bickering
between main characters in the midst of
our self reflection leadership and the
terminus in the face of the feet,
George Rr Martin also doesn't forget to
show us the humanity on a larger skill
and how the decisions of our high born
characters affect the lives of thousands
otherwise,
nameless and forgotten people.
The lab's called agreement to make,
trying to sneak away with a stolen horse
and some gold cups.
How's the NNC to them?
It's through these brief glimpses in the
background through shots of commoners
fleeing soldiers,
vomiting before battle in a sense that
the good and the righteous only stands
to lose in this war of kings.
Boys will never come back.
Feel free will the west.
It's about showing this that Martin
personalizes and the generalized,
the conflict to the very bottom of the
game of thrones hierarchy.
Throughout the episode,
Tyrian is the one character who truly
grasps the wider humanity at play,
who understands the gap between the ones
of the high born and wants of those
staking their order
for your kids.
Don't fight for his kingdom.
Your means the fact that your Katie's.
It's only fitting that Syrian has been
known to be Martins,
own embodiment of who he'd be or who he
wants to be in the world of game of
chromes and it's complete deconstruction
of the US versus them narrative.
Blackwater shows itself to be highly
critical of the feudal succession system
and the senselessness of the conflict
being driven by people who send her
again,
describes as,
this is a killer.
Atlanta's just kill us,
kill us.
It's in this pessimistic,
yet realistic view of the world of game,
of thrones and fruit,
a depiction of a truly great conflict in
which good and bad exist on both sides
and inside the individual characters
themselves,
but the futility of it all becomes
everclear and in which game of thrones
uniqueness truly shines as George
himself puts it in response to the
battles likeness to deloitte or rings
battle of Helm's deep.
The ward at Tolkien wrote about was war
for the fate of civilization and the
future of humanity,
and that's become the template.
I'm not sure that's a good template
though.
It's all key model lead generations of
fantasy writers to produce these endless
series of dark Lord Cinder Evil Minions
who were all very ugly and wear black
clothes,
but the vast majority of wars throughout
history are not like that.
Although structurally very similar its
core,
a black water can really be seen as a
sort of anti helm's deep and whereas the
battle of the bastards might be a
different type of battle in its essence,
it has a lot more in common with helm's
deep and it's all keen template in
general being an outlier and for some
maybe a breath of fresh air.
There's really nothing wrong with this
in itself,
but it seems that the final two seasons
of the show,
we'll perhaps somewhat unavoidably move
ever more into the direction of
conventional talking fantasy.
But before we get there though,
there are still battles to be fought
which could and shoot.
Bring out what makes game of thrones
great in the first place.
If visually compelling,
morally gray battle that exposes true
character in the face of death,
the question remains,
however,
how to show will choose to deal with
their very own conflict of heart and to
what extent it has already decided on a
more conventional and perhaps safer path
in the end.
Will door to salvation for our
characters opened at the very last
moment or will it remain closed and will
the story dare to show itself to be to
entitle key truly is
and who.
All right,
that's the end of yet another video
essay.
Black water has to be one of my favorite
game of thrones episodes and I hope this
video gave you his sentence.
Why as I'm recording this,
it's only a couple of hours until the
release of season seven's first episode.
Which direction do you guys think the
show will take and how do you think it
will all end next year?
I would love to hear your thoughts on
this anyway.
If he wants to help our channel grow,
check out our patrion page or hop on
over to paypal to show your support and
as always we wanted to thank you all for
watching and see you in the next one.